oui alors attention c'est parti on y va
première question ici la voix de la
vérité
bonsoir laurent vous êtes sur un bateau
avec catherine barma laurent gerra et
cyril hanouna
vous ne pouvez en sauver que deux
lesquels catherine barma et cyril
hanouna
oui oui oui la mois déjà chez sur des
dons je suis content merci à quoi
laurent gerra ce point non mais je m'en
fous je connais pas je connais plus donc
le jour où peut naître on se parlera
jamais franchement j'ai quand même passé
suffisamment d'années avec catherine
pour la sauver et vous que je connais
plutôt que de façon sympathique alors
que lui ça fait des années qu'on s'est
pas adressé la parole et de la peine je
suis simplement c'est que j'ai rien j'ai
rien contre lui je suis le jeu après
tout je que je descendais les locks
connaît le mieux où il a développé l'art
et de droite je suis là des bleus après
il ya bien aller et on embrasse moi
j'aime de laurent gerra aussi et c'est
vrai que voilà j'espère que vous allez
pouvoir tous les doubles savait faire
des choses en somme allez c'est parti
question ici la voix de la vérité
cyril vous êtes sur le point de vous
réconcilier avec laurent ruquier
êtes vous prêt à faire de même avec
arthur non
[Musique]
[Rires]
auparavant une seule a raison parce
qu'en fait on ne comprend pas cette
brouille avec qui avec avec arthur non
mais on va pas revenir là dessus et si
les gens disent demande parce que doublé
mais qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé entre
eux que je ne sais pas à fond dans ses
excès c'est que voilà c'est une
accumulation de choses c'est que moi
j'aime les gens fous et c'est vrai que
voilà et voilà s'est lamenté les cinq
sens et on a toujours c'est vrai que oui
ça va ça vient ça va ça vient enfin là
ça va encore investir et faire plein de
choses voilà je vais pas rentrer là
dessus bercy question est là la machine
en marche parce qu'on a bâtie demain on
ici la voix de la vérité
laurent est ce que vous avez déjà croisé
cyril dans la rue et fait mine de ne pas
le voir
je ne crois pas non laurent apparemment
vous montez mais c'est possible que je
n'ai pas lu mais non je vous ai pas vu
la dernière fois je vais croiser vous
savez où c'était et ou à la coupe du
monde de football c'est vrai alors ça
c'est exceptionnel ça je vais raconter
parce qu'on était c'était pas la folie
tous les deux non et non je j'arrive au
brésil ont pas encore en brésil 2014
2014 pas et qu'un pote au brésil
première personne que je vois arriver je
sors du métro pour aller au stade
première personne que je vois l'eau
c'est à croire au brésil pour hubert la
finale c'est bien je n'ai jamais croisé
à paris la finale et gaspard proust
était avec nous avait perdu son billet
avait perdu son billet entre les deux
contrôles on n'a jamais retrouvé n'a pas
pu voir le ballon lui c'est vrai ce
n'est pas vous c'est pas pour maintenant
c'était bon alors question sur ici la
voix de la vérité
laurent avez vous reçu des sms ou cyril
invectivé quelqu'un de votre entourage
de mon entourage non mois de mai
[Rires]
vas-y que ce n'est pas très méchant mais
mais mais si l'on échange que l'on peut
avoir parfois mais là laurent julien
truc
tous les deux on a toujours discuté et
c'est pour ça que mon âme envoyé un truc
comme ça en fait j'aurais pop up je me
dis alors on se reparlera plus tard on
s'est reparlé jeudi doit avoir pu à ce
temps là ici la voix de la vérité
cyril pouvez vous dire ce que vous
pensez réellement de la nouvelle
émission de laurent ruquier
pas franchement oui il faut que
développe alors non je pense que la
nouvelle émission
moi je pense que laurent ruquier en vrai
et je te le dis le rendre ta pas
vraiment besoin de concept pour moi tu
fais partie des animateurs ont dit je
pense qu'à pas une personne qui connaît
donc une émission tout le monde dit je
regarde brut et le regarder ruquier le
samedi soir
ça s'appelle voilà où vous êtes en
direct que ce soit on n'est pas couché
franchement on vient voir laurent rue
je pense franchement qu'il y a j'adore
le producteur avec qui tu es et
inscrivait un producteur philippe
thuillier que j'adore et je pense qu'en
fait si je n'ai pas de conseils à donner
j'adore l'émission je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de choses mais je
pense que la première personne qu'on a
envie de voir dans ton émission c'est
toi ça tombe bien je suis tout seul à
l'animé maintenant c'est vrai j'avais
avant j'avais des partenaires non mais
là où vous avez raison cyril où tu as
raison je sais pas trop mais c'est qu'il
ya des animateurs et vous en faites
partie qui sont plus forts que le
concept mais ça nous arrive aussi
parfois d'animer des émissions dont le
concept est plus fort que nous moi par
exemple quand j'anime les enfants de la
télé
le concept est plus fort que moi les
grosses têtes le concept est plus fort
que moi en revanche quand j'anime un
talk show le tokyo évidemment fait la
différence c'est vrai pouvoir dix ans
c'était vrai pour marc olivier fogiel
c'est vrai pour vous c'est vrai pour moi
c'est le nom qui fait la différence avec
le talk show truman show ça reste que tu
te régales laurent à faire on les
enfants de la télé on est en direct les
deux les enfants de la télé c'est une
vraie récréation on est en direct c'est
beaucoup de travail parce qu'il faut
vraiment moi je prends soin vraiment à
lire les livres des invités à écouter
des disques à voir les films
oui mais sur une quotidienne on le sait
c'est pas possible de toute façon on
marque sur une bosse c'est pas contre
eux contre série que si ça passe quand
je faisais on a tout essayé
c'est impossible sur une quotidienne on
ne peut pas venir que sur leur emblème
sur une annuelle mais en tout cas sion
une hebdo c'est pour ça que j'aime bien
ce rythme là moi je travaille beaucoup
j'aime bien ça d'abord j'aime découvrir
les livres les films même de gens vers
lesquels je n'irai pas forcément et
c'est ce qui fait le plaisir pour moi
d'animer ce genre d'émission voilà
pourquoi on a des choses en commun voilà
pour les plantations on découvre et on
aime lire oui une même foi je voulais
dire lire s'est refusé de mourir voilà